former president Donald Trump is
defending himself against a republican
backlash over his recent dinner with two
known anti-semites as you may know by
now Trump hosted white nationalist and
Holocaust denier Nick Fuentes at
Mar-A-Lago last week along with the
rapper yay formerly known as Kanye West
and then yesterday House minority leader
Kevin McCarthy and Senate minority
leader Mitch McConnell publicly
condemned the meeting
I don't think anybody should be spending
any time with Nick Fuentes he has no
place in this Republican party there is
no room in the Republican Party
for anti-semitism
or white supremacy
and anyone meeting
with people advocating that point of
view
in my judgment
are highly unlikely to ever be elected
president of the United States
CBS News Chief political analyst John
Dickerson is here John exactly the
person to talk to on a morning like this
uh you know Mitch McConnell did not say
Donald Trump's name yeah which is
noteworthy what else stands out to you
in What Might Have Been A Familiar kind
of episode from the realm of Donald
Trump in the last five years well that's
what stands out is how familiar it is
that even when you come up against
anti-Semitism there is this Collective
silence at first about taking him on
either because Republicans are afraid of
taking on Donald Trump because he has
littered the roadside with Republicans
who've tried to take him on on moral
issues and he's won there are no moral
slam dunks with Donald Trump and his
party in part because of his supporters
who defend him and because we're in a
time where Republicans the worst sin is
giving Aiden Comfort to the other party
so if by criticizing Donald Trump on no
matter what the issue it looks like
you're giving Aid in Comfort to
Democrats or the media then they then
they rally around him so and there's no
one Republican whose responsibility it
is to uphold these standards you might
say well anti-Semitism or racism it's
everybody's job but that's not the
political world we're in right now in
the Republican party but can we just
look at the history for just a second of
Donald Trump he won for president uh he
won the presidency by saying racist
things that didn't seem to stop anybody
well that's to say well that's that's
that's why I said to Tony it's it's this
seems very familiar I mean think about
it Donald Trump ran for president saying
that that Barack Obama was not born in
America so that's just a straight up
racist play yes then as a candidate
before he's elected he said that a judge
of Mexican heritage couldn't judge him
fairly which Paul Ryan at the time said
was a textbook statement of racism then
Mitch McConnell said that that Donald
Trump was ambivalent about the KKK and
David Duke and that that was
reprehensible all of those things were
said and he was still elected after
Charlottesville this was he also the
president said something that Lindsey
Graham said you were making it morally
equivalent between people carrying Nazi
flags and the people protesting those
flags none of that hurt Donald Trump so
is the thinking for the Republicans well
I'm not going to say anything because if
you do you say it at your own Peril you
say it your own Peril and also what they
know is that when they criticize Donald
Trump he doesn't say what doesn't do
what previous politicians would have
done in an instance like this which is
recognizing oh I did something bad I'm
gonna sorry I wait wrong right Donald
Trump runs in the middle grabs the the
lightning rod and stays there no
Republican wants Donald Trump in the
middle of the conversation who worries
about the national reputation of the
party and they saw the downside of that
in the 2022 elections where Donald
Trump's candidates and his Persona hurt
the Republican party I worry about this
Behavior though John being normalized
that after a while we'll just think well
it really isn't that big a deal when it
still really is a big deal for sure and
it still really is wrong well what the
former president is saying is you know
oh I didn't know which is another
familiar kind of uh talking point when
he has been accused of playing footsie
with with white nationalists before this
is Thanksgiving dinner with a white
nationalist Bennett says I didn't know
the guy this isn't a fourth row to
condemnation events no I mean well
racism it's hard for Donald Trump to say
he's the smartest person in the world
and he doesn't know so that's the start
the second thing is
Donald Trump has a TR a quick trigger
finger when it comes to criticizing
people or speaking out about outrages I
mean think about how many times he he
tweeted about NFL players taking a knee
something like 30 times right I mean
he's on it like that but when it comes
to racism and anti-Semitism he starts
mumbling he's hard to read she doesn't
know when it came to Charlottesville he
he never condemned on Twitter he issued
six tweets about it never condemned
white supremacy never condemned the
Nazis or anything so for a person who is
an expert at calling out people and
showing outrage he seems to have very
little of it for any of these things
that are the most outrageous what does
this mean that's I mean we keep playing
this record over and over again what
does it means president what if anything
should be done potential presidential
right well 2024 we'll see what it means
for his run when you talk about
normalizing things Gail when you know
when the Republican party we just saw
the the head of the Oath Keepers get
convicted right that's something that
the Republican party January 6 they said
was legitimate political discourse when
it comes to Donald Trump there has been
this thing where he crosses a line and
then his supporters basically just lower
the line or change the line they've
changed the standard which is what
normalizing is so does this get
normalized or do Republicans say because
Donald Trump seemed to have been
somewhat toxic in the last election uh
this is it's kind of a combination it's
both a moral failing on Donald Trump's
part but also because he's no longer a
winner then they can speak out and it's
more powerful for them to do so or it's
like every other instance in which
there's a lot of chatter and then it
goes away and he still retains the the
supremacy in the middle of the
Republican Party John you're the best we
appreciate you you can make the most
complicated topics very digestible for
us